an American company announces the
possibility of millions of doses of
vaccine by October stupid controversies
breakout when president from visits
Michigan and Joe Biden tells black
voters that they aren't actually black
unless they vote for Joe Biden i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protect it at expressvpn comm / Ben well
before we get into the controversies of
the day and there are many controversies
of the day first I want to just give a
quick shout out to our advertisers they
keep the show going we really appreciate
them one of our brand new advertisers is
a group that helps you invest in ways
that you might not have thought that you
could invest it is a way that a lot of
people have gotten very well that is
investing in companies at the startup
phase it's a company called our crowd
and they help you invest in the
important work that startup companies
are doing they've made it so that in
creditor investors can join with them at
our crowd and help crowdsource investing
for a lot of different people so our
crowd has a crowdsourced investing
platform they give accredited investors
access to early-stage funding rounds and
some of the most promising companies in
the world they help you invest before
the companies go public so you're really
getting in on the ground floor with a
lot of this stuff our crowd companies
have been bought by Nike Oracle uber
Comcast Intel snap and more you can set
up an hour crowd account for free and
invest in pre IPO companies which is a
great way to get started in investing
alongside professor professional venture
capitalist one of the companies for
example that our crowd is now
representing is a company called MIG
Beck's MIG VAX has shared that they were
uniquely poised to develop a Kovan 19
vaccine because they spent the last four
years developing similar and successful
avian vaccines when coronavirus surfaced
make VAX quickly pivoted to developing a
kovin 19 vaccine they're now in
preclinical trials and working quickly
to produce an effective vaccine the
vaccine is oral and doesn't include the
virus itself so it should be easier to
administer and safer to produce and make
VAX is developing more than more than a
single vaccine it's designed to be a
vaccine platform so it allows for fast
adaptation of new vaccines in the future
so our crowd is the company that is
helping to bring the possibility of
crowd-sourced investment in pre-ipo
companies like MIG vets you should go
check them out right now by the way the
folks who run it are people who I know
really well like I've known since I was
a child so I really do trust them learn
more about investing it in companies
like MIG backs at our crowd comm slash
Shapiro setting up your account is free
get started right now at our crowd comm
/khroe that's oh you are CRO WD our
crowd comm slash apparel and getting an
investing on the ground floor in
promising new companies our crowd comm
slash apparel go check them out right
now ok so we're gonna get to the big
controversy of the day in just a moment
that controversy of the day being Joe
Biden deciding that basically just gonna
let it all hang out he's now going to
say that you're not a black American
unless you vote for Joe Biden which is a
pretty incredible pitch only a Democrat
theoretically could get away with that
but first let's talk about a couple of
things that actually really matter so
right now the polls are showing some
pretty significant movement in the
direction of reopening so just a couple
of weeks ago the overwhelming majority
of the American public was not in favor
of reopening and that was largely due to
media coverage of kovat 19 the
suggestion that reopening would
inevitably lead to extraordinary levels
of death and doom that simply would not
occur if we just continue to lock down
presumably until forever and the problem
was of course that that conflicted with
the original flatten the curve message
which was we are going to lock you down
until we have made it so that the system
will not be overwhelmed and then we'll
let you out again
well right now nearly 46 percent have
46% of Americans according to a new poll
by Politico and the Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health nearly half of
Americans believe their state's governor
should allow non-essential businesses to
be open in their state in the next month
to reduce financial difficulties for
businesses and people about half think
non-essential businesses in their states
does you want 51% should be closed until
the spread of kovat 19 has been
contained but again that is very vague
because who the hell knows what that
means the spread of kovin 19 has been
contained I mean if you by the way those
two things are not in conflict
containment is a is a pretty malleable
term right there 61% of Republicans
believe their states governors should
allow non-essential businesses to be
open more than two-thirds of Democrats
69% think such businesses should be
closed until the spread of the virus is
contained six in 10 owners and managers
of small or medium-sized businesses 60%
favored non-essential businesses being
open in their states in addition of
those whose households have experienced
forms of employment loss since the start
of Kovan 19 outbreak 52 percent favorite
businesses being open in the next month
in contrast a majority of those whose
households have not experienced
employment lost favored non-essential
businesses remaining closed so in other
words the people who want to reopen are
people who own businesses and people who
work at businesses that are closed right
now that those are the numbers so does
not a bunch of elites sitting there and
being like we just want people who are
poor to die that is not a thing instead
what is happening is pretty obviously
something different which is if you're
unable to work if you've lost your job
you would like to get back to work and
the opinions are changing because what
we have seen is that some states are
reopening and
not experiencing wild upticks in the
number of deaths or infections in their
state in fact one of the things that we
have seen is across the country a
flattening when it comes to the number
of positive tests compared to the number
of tests being taken the percentage of
positive tests is actually continuing to
go down the daily deaths by the way are
also continuing to go down in the United
States we have actually declined rather
markedly since we were in the middle of
April so that is that is good news
by the way hospital resource use has
been in significant decline and never
hit the high numbers by the way it is
also worth noting that there is now a
lot of retrospective study of the
Imperial College model and it turns out
that the the data were simply amassed
that the coding was an absolute mess and
that was used as the basis for locking
down entire countries essentially the UK
Telegraph reported just a few weeks ago
well actually a few days ago they cover
19 modelling that sent Britain into
lockdown shutting the economy and
leaving millions unemployed has been
slammed by a series of experts professor
Neil Ferguson's computer coding was
derided as quote totally unreliable by
leading figures who warned it was
something he wouldn't stake your life on
the model credited with forcing the
government to make a u-turn and
introduce a nationwide lockdown is quote
a buggy mess that looks more like a bowl
of angel-hair pasta than a finely tuned
piece of programming said david richards
co-founder of british data technology
company w a and disco he said in our
commercial reality we would fire anyone
for developing code like this and any
business that relied on it to produce
software for sale would likely go bust
ok so that was the model that people
were using to shut down entire countries
so well done everybody now that doesn't
mean that there isn't going to be an
uptick in cases maybe an uptick in
deaths it also doesn't mean that the
summer is necessarily gonna kill this
off what we have seen is that it is
unclear whether this is heat the pennmen
right India is seeing a fairly large
uptick in cases Brazil obviously is a
warm place and they've seen tremendous
levels of caseload and death what is
clear is that as people are going out
it's not spreading as fast as people
thought it would and a large part of
that is because when you are out and
about and you are not in enclosed spaces
you are not in an enclosed spaces and
that's really how this thing passes is
you're right up next to somebody for 10
15 minutes you're talking with them
there's not a lot of air circulation if
you're outside the chances of you
getting this are really really low in
fact there was that early study from
China that showed that of a thousand
cases in China like two had come
from people talking outside and they
were in really close proximity to one
another so all of that is good news can
we be cautiously optimistic are we
allowed to do that or are we supposed to
be just downbeat all the time if you
watch the media obviously as we
discussed yesterday they're urging you
to be downbeat nearly all the time
but that is not a good idea I mean we
should be upbeat when the evidence
warrants being upbeat and the evidence
is warranting us being at least
cautiously optimistic so long as we
continue to engage in the responsible
activities of social distancing and
wearing a mask that you should be doing
I'm not one of the people who says you
should run out willy nilly in the
streets and and not wear a mask if
you're indoors with other people and and
you know make them feel uncomfortable
mostly because that is what happens or
if you're around people who are
vulnerable however I'm also not a person
who's gonna say you can't associate with
other people my wife and I the other day
we went over to a couple's house that we
know we sat in their backyard we
socially distanced from them was
delightful you couldn't you could
actually see other human beings it's
alright you can do it meanwhile in other
good news the New York Times is
reporting that the u.s. says it will
provide up to 1.2 billion dollars to a
drug company to develop a vaccine from
an oxford lab the US Department of
Health and Human Services said on
Thursday would provide up to 1.2 billion
dollars to the drug company AstraZeneca
to develop a potential coronavirus
vaccine from a laboratory at Oxford the
deal with Astra Zeneca is the forth
vaccine research agreement the
department has disclosed by far the
largest the money will play for what
will pay for a clinical trial of the
potential vaccine in the United States
this summer with about 30,000 volunteers
we're gonna have some information really
really fast and whether this thing works
the HHS statement said the agency and
AstraZeneca are quote collaborating to
make available at least 300 million
doses and projected the first doses
could be available as early as October
which would be extraordinary
extraordinary I mean from the time of
the development of vaccine to
distribution of the vaccine inside of
six months that'd be absolutely
incredible it would be a miracle of
science it really would be and being
able to reopen the economy by October
because vaccinations are available be an
unbelievable thing most public health
experts and scientists think a viable
vaccine would probably not be available
until sometime next year at the earliest
but as for Zeneca is saying now we're
actually moving toward millions of doses
by October assuming that the vaccine
shows safety and efficacy we will start
large clinical trials in the United
States as well as another
of the world in over the Sun appears in
june/july equally as we speak we're
beefing up our women affects weak
capabilities and we are confidence that
we will be able to deliver 100 million
dollars in October assuming of course
that this action is working hey that
would be excellent news all of us would
be excellent news so it's time for some
cautious optimism this is a very very
good thing right in in some bad news
we'll tell you it's so funny there there
all these people who are out there
saying you're a science denier Science
denier if you believe that we should end
lockdowns and that we should go back and
cautious fashion your science tonight
you just want to kill people wait until
I tell you about a poll of Americans on
what they will do if President Trump
touts a vaccine because you want talk
about science denial I'll tell you about
that in just one second first let's talk
about something amazing so I've been
talking about my helix league mattress
for a really long time but helix has now
gone beyond the boudoir and they started
making sofas they just launched a brand
new company it's called all form they
are making premium customizable sofas
and chairs shipped directly to your door
so we all love our sofa right we all
love our couches an enormous amount of
time on our sofa and our couch why would
you not get a fantastic so far couch
shipped directly to your door and these
things are great my wife and I just
ordered one we cannot wait to sit on it
so what makes an all for himself are
really cool for starters it is the
easiest way you can customize this so if
I using premium materials at a fraction
of the cost of traditional stores you
can pick your fabric the sofa color the
color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
they've got armchairs and loveseats all
the way up to an 8 seat sectional so
there's something for everyone and you
can always start small and buy more
seats later on if you want your all for
himself at a grow and change when you
move so really is customizable it's like
you kind of bolt on more more sofa it's
awesome all firm sofas are also
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping in the past if you
want to order or so if I could take
weeks or months to arrive all form takes
three to seven days to arrive in the
mail you can assemble it yourself in
just a few minutes with no tools which
is fantastic because that is my least
favorite thing is you go to one of these
big-box stores and then it takes you
three hours to assemble the sofa that
you just bought honestly it's so easy to
do this I have an all form so fetcher I
picked out a three seat sofa with the
chaise in the sand color with the
expresso legs it looks great and I'll be
honest I didn't pick it my wife did
because she does all the furniture
picking and her how she was super
impressed with the entire process it
really is easy they also have forever
warranty like literally forever
I mean right now have you ever
appreciated your couch more well you're
definitely going to appreciate it when
you use all form comm slash bet and find
your perfect sofa today check out all
forum comm /ban all forum is offering a
20% off all orders for our listeners and
all forum comm / Ben and that's all
forum comm / Ben you're gonna love it it
really is fantastic I cannot wait to sit
I'm IO forum sofa all forum comm / Ben
and you get 20% off all orders right now
that is a solid solid deal ok so
meanwhile when we talk about science
denial when we talk about people who are
undermining the science there's a new
poll from Reuters Ipsos and it found
that 36% of Americans say they will be
less likely to take an eventual
coronavirus vaccine if President Trump
vouchers for its safety
so if thou she gets up there and says
this thing's safe and then Trump gets up
there and says it is it's unbelievably
say people like I'm not taking it
anymore I don't know what to tell you if
you are making your medical decisions
based on what President Trump says
either for or against this is because
you are being a dumb-dumb hey you should
listen to your doctor and if your doctor
tells you that a vaccine is safe then
you should listen to your doctor the
survey found less than 2/3 of Americans
overall said they were very or somewhat
interested in a vaccine for kovin 19
which Reuters points out falls well
short of the 70% of Americans who would
need to be immune through a vaccine or
prior infection in order to achieve herd
immunity nearly one in five Republicans
said they have no interest in a vaccine
that's more than twice the proportion of
Democrats who said the same because
there's X that there are a lot of anti
vaccine activists inside the Republican
community because they don't like
government centralization or because
they don't trust scientists whatever it
is that's idiotic
vaccines are useful obviously you want
to wait to find out what the thing is
safe you want to wait to see who attests
to the safety of the vaccine we have had
instances in American history like in
the 1970s with Gerald for pushing out a
vaccine that actually was not perfectly
safe
you want to make sure the thing is safe
because we're rushing forward with it
and also you want to calculate whether
your chances as a young person are
better or worse if you get the vaccine
than if you actually get Kovan 19 but in
reality we do need lots and lots of
people to take the defects it will I be
taking the vaccine you bet your ass I'll
be taking the vaccine if the thing is
safe of course I'll take the vaccine
I'm a big proponents of vaccinations but
it is hilarious to me that so many
Democrats are going to base their
opinion of a vaccine on whether
President Trump likes it or not
this suggests that you're doing life
wrong a meanwhile speaking of doing
laughs wrong the continued conversation
over the economy it continues to be
unbelievably stupid because many members
of the media have this narrative and
they just will not let go of it Paul
Krugman who will just hang on to a
narrative like a dog with a with a bone
it's truly incredible this is a man who
has the the capacity for nuance to
thinking I'm just gonna read you the
last two titles of his last two columns
Paul Krugman over the near x 1.is we
should help workers not kill them I feel
like there's a third choice where we
help them and also don't kill them on
the one hand I would love to help
workers on the other hand I don't want
to kill them so I'm I'm confused by your
binary were those the two choices
helping workers and killing them I feel
like there's a third way we were like
helping them and also not killing them
by letting them go back to work safely
and securely that was titled one today's
nuanced column from Paul Krugman is how
many will die for the Dow because now
he's just suggesting that if you want to
go back to work by the way again that
poll from Politico shows that 52 percent
of people who've lost a job want to go
back to work and by the ways the checks
start to run out from the federal
government more people are gonna want to
go back to work and as the prices start
to dive in certain areas and rise and
others people are going to want to go
back to work but now according to Paul
Krugman if you want people to gradually
and safely go back to work it's because
you want to kill people this narrative
they just will not let go of it it's
incredible it's incredible the evidence
does not bear out the narrative doesn't
matter Paul Krugman is gonna hang on to
this sucker he is a terrier in your pant
leg it's unbelievable he says Trump has
abandoned his original strategy they
won't say this explicitly and then
throwing up various disingenuous
explanations for what they're doing but
they're basically of Americans must die
for the Dow really what why is that my
strategy that thousands of Americans
must die for the Dow am i telling
anybody they have to go back to work am
i telling everybody that they need to
leave their homes have I not stated on
this program repeatedly that if you have
a pre-existing condition or if you are
extra if you are vulnerable to cope in
nineteen that we should make provision
for you that we should allow you to
continue to draw unemployment benefits
but that if you are young and healthy
and you are at low risk for dying of
Kovan 19 then that's just gonna have to
become a background risk of life that is
not saying that people should die that
is saying that we all make risk
calculations in public policy
Paul Krugman still clings to this notion
that you never have to make a risk
calculation in
public policy instead you can just pay
people to stay home forever right he's
doing this because he's pushing against
the idea that we should pay people's
unemployment for more than their salary
is worth through the end of the year
just don't worry about incurring debt he
says that that's fine he says now this
isn't this isn't like a real scientific
thing weird because all of Europe is
also reopening so is he yelling at the
Europeans for wanting to raise the Dow
Jones Industrial Average or is he just a
liar this stuff is so irritating and so
unbelievably stupid and when people say
that they are worried about blowing out
the spending that it leads to waste and
fraud what listen we all understand it's
an emergency situation we're all
embracing policies that we didn't like
five minutes ago we get it but to
pretend there are no costs and benefits
in and analyzing risk portfolios and
profiles is idiotic it will get to all
this in just one second and then we will
get to the Trump Biden race which is
beginning to heat up the media really
putting their thumb on the scale
naturally naturally you knew this was
coming we'll get to that momentarily
first let us talk about the fact that
life is incredibly risky and right now
you know life is throwing people a lot
of unexpected curveballs the good news
is that you can insure against
unexpected curveballs and this is why
you ought to go check out policy genius
right now policy genius is an insurance
marketplace
there's a giant demand for life
insurance right now so if you're looking
to get life insurance here's how they
can help policy genius we'll compare
quotes from the top life insurance
companies all in one place it takes just
a few minutes to compare quotes from the
top insurers and find your best price
this doesn't just save a lot of legwork
you could say 1500 bucks or more per
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape for free
they're in contact with life insurance
companies every day monitoring
developments helping customers navigate
every step there really is no reason to
wait when it comes to life insurance
like gee you just get a carrot taking
care of it out you don't have to think
about it anymore and you've done the
responsible thing for your family and
for yourself
so if you're one of many people looking
to buy life insurance code check out
policy genius they also do disability
and auto and home insurance all sorts of
insurance over a policy genius policy
genius will find you the best rate
handle the process from soup to nuts you
can stop worrying about life insurance
and get back to your daily life go check
out policy genius commet right now
that's policy genius calm so contrast
the perspective of Paul Krugman what the
perspective of a latte czar who is the
US Secretary of Health and Human
Services and he points out the
sacrifices Americans have made through
social distancing
have helped slow down the spread of the
virus and save lives moving forward we
need to confront the misconception that
going back to normal life just means
balancing the health risks of reopening
against the economic cost of aggressive
social distancing returning to normal
isn't about balancing health versus the
economy it's about balancing health
versus health the health risks of Cova
19 balance against the health social and
economic costs of keeping Main streets
across the United States closed for
business
getting this ballot balance right isn't
simple it will look different for every
state business and family the Trump
administration is committed to helping
each state and all Americans have the
information and tools they need to
safely reopen and he is correct about
this again this is obviously a more
nuanced position than you want to reopen
it's cuz you want grandma to die idiots
like Paul Krugman are gonna have to
explain why it is then that Gavin Newsom
is reopening why it is then that Andrew
Cuomo is reopening Alex azar says the
economic process crisis brought on by
the virus is a silent killer estimates
suggest that each one percentage point
increase in the unemployment rate
translates into a 1% increase in suicide
deaths and a more than 3 percent
increase in opioid deaths which means
this virus induced recession will likely
cost tens of thousands of excess deaths
one study of the 1982 recession found
that Americans who face higher
unemployment suffered approximately
40,000 excess deaths by age 65 as well
as more divorces in having fewer
children shortening this economic crisis
through a safe reopening could save
thousands of lives
meanwhile at a time of social stress
states are seeing a decline in reports
of child maltreatment which is likely
going unreported because children are
isolated from teachers and others who
keep an eye on the vulnerable the Cova
19 response is also restricted access to
health care data suggests the number of
Americans receiving important
preventative services are down
significantly mammograms are down 87%
colonoscopies are down 90% more than 1.7
million new cancer cases are diagnosed
per year in the United States if we see
an 80 percent drop in cancer cases
identified approximately we could
already have 200,000 or more undiagnosed
cancer cases as a result breast cancer
surgeries are down approximately
two-thirds since January vaccine
administrations were down 60% from early
January to mid March which means you
could see a measles outbreak in the fall
right all of this stuff is really really
bad and you have to balance all of this
these are these are needs you have to
balance their reports from California
there are California doctors who are now
saying that in their areas they are
seeing more
deaths by suicide than they are from
kovat 19 dr. michael de bois Blanc of
John Muir Medical Center in Walnut Creek
California said that the numbers are
unprecedented
he said he's seen as a year worth of
suicides in the last four weeks alone he
says I think this was originally put in
place to flatten the curve and make sure
hospitals have the resources to take
care of Kovach patients we have
resources you that our other community
health is suffering again I talked to
people in the medical industry literally
every day they're sitting at their desks
doing nothing because people are not
coming into the hospitals for the care
that they need because they were told
that they weren't supposed to come and
stay home if you can well now it turns
out that hospitals are firing people in
the middle of a pandemic it's incredible
meanwhile it turns out that over in
Washington state a fraud Network
siphoned hundreds of millions of dollars
off of the unemployment funds so you can
do this for a little while you can do
the pour money into the into the hose
for a little while but pretty quickly it
turns into a fraud program prickly
pretty quickly it becomes obvious how
much money is being wasted and pretty
quickly it becomes obvious that
government is not a substitute for
having a job and trusting your neighbors
to be responsible citizens officials
confirm this fraud on the same day the
federal government reported another 2.4
million American workers filing for
jobless benefits this week the total is
a staggering thirty eight point six
million people have filed for jobless
benefits in the last nine weeks alone
which is totally insane unprecedented in
American history the Labor Department
has found that a large majority of
laid-off workers according to the New
York Times expect their joblessness to
be temporary but there's growing concern
among economists that many jobs will
never come back
Nicholas Blum economist at Stanford he
said I hate to say it this is gonna take
longer and look grimmer than we thought
this is why it's actually important to
reopen the economy as fast as possible
one of the reasons it's really important
to do that as fast as possible is
specifically because you need to let the
market iron out all of the
inefficiencies in the market as we move
into a new world we're gonna have to
figure out exactly how restaurants cope
by restaurants for example are gonna the
market does help create a feedback loop
of what is needed
so right now commercial real estate is
getting devastated obviously because why
would you rent commercial real estate
when you can't go into the office but
let's say that you're a restaurant you
might actually need more commercial real
estate one of the reasons you might need
more commercial real estate is you knock
down the wall between your little store
fronts and the storefront next to you
and suddenly you can actually fit
number of people you need to fit in
there with the social distancing in
other words getting back to the real
world and letting people make decisions
about their own economic livelihood is
going to be necessary in order to see an
uptick in the economy centralized
government bureaucracy and pouring money
into the economy at the same time
they're telling companies whether they
can and cannot open is a recipe for
disaster
more and more Americans are realizing
this and that's a good thing I mean I
think that that that is good it means
that Americans are zealous about their
freedoms they should be zealous about
their freedoms it's a very very
important thing by the way this is
president Trump's pitch so President
Trump was in Michigan yesterday and he
said listen Americans want to go back to
work he is correct about this by the
polling data were about evenly split
but among the Americans who have a job
and just lost one majority do you want
to go back to work and that's going to
increase over time it's not going to
decrease over time the momentum for
reopening is obvious it is clear we are
moving toward reopening and that's a
good thing here as president Trump
yesterday at the Ford factory in
Michigan there's a tremendous pent up
demand and that occlusive cars Americans
who need and want to return to work
should not be vilified they should be
supported
unlike many politicians and journalists
for those who are a living with their
own two hands working remotely is just
not an option you don't have the option
of doing that okay so he is right about
that he's correct I mean the people who
are being disproportionately hit by this
thing our blue-collar low-income workers
those are the people whose jobs are
disappearing and in a government check
is not a substitute for a job it is not
a substitute for being involved in the
creation of products and services for
other people to consume it's just not
jobs actually do provide a level of
meaning that a government check does not
this is one of the things that universal
basic income will never solve universal
basic income the idea is that if we give
you a universal basic income you won't
have to take a job you don't want to and
you'll be able to sit there and create
art all day question how much art have
people been creating during quarantine
really or how much have people actually
been engaging in just sitting around
watching TV
I think these stats are pretty telling
actually okay meanwhile we're gonna get
to the Trump controversies in Michigan
and then we'll get to the controversy
that really should be okay the big
controversy of the day and that is Joe
Biden and the 2020 election question is
is it a referendum on Biden Biden or is
it a referendum
from so far it's been a referendum on
Trump but it could easily turn into a
referendum on Joe Biden we'll get to
that in just one moment first let's talk
about the fact that as we transition
back into a economy that is free and
open as we move into a new world of
different demand and supply curves well
people are gonna need jobs and people
are gonna need employees thank god
there's a company like zip recruiter out
there helping you find the job that you
need and helping you find the employees
that you need if you are an employer if
you're looking for a job zip recruiters
working with you to find the right job
at faster they are dedicated to helping
you get hired from caretaking to
delivering food and goods to building
medical facilities supplying protective
equipment and so much more in fact zip
recruiters app will send you up-to-date
job openings so you can be one of the
first to apply if you're actively hiring
zip recruiter will invite candidates to
apply to your most urgent roles making
it faster and easier to reach the people
you need by connecting people who need
jobs and companies that need people
zip recruiter is working with all of us
so we can just keep moving forward that
is what is important right now zip
recruit is making it happen for you
they're also making it possible for me
to get rid of my useless employees and
get new employees never has been there
there have been a better time to shop if
you are an employer right now let's all
work together at zip recruiter comm
slash work together that is zip
recruiter dot-com / work together go
check them out right now they're doing
really important work and more
importantly they're helping you find
really important work ok so president
Trump was in Michigan yesterday and this
created the opportunity for the media to
go nuts on President Trump in a series
of really really dumb controversies like
a bunch of really dumb controversies
meanwhile Joe Biden was literally saying
this morning in an interview that you're
not black if you don't vote for him and
media will gloss over that like
immediately the differential way in
which controversies are treated by the
media is an incredible thing and I spend
a lot of time criticizing the media that
is because the media are the filter
through which you see information one of
the things we do on the show is provide
a different filter through which you see
information I'm not gonna say there's no
filter there is I'm the filter but at
least try to bring to attention things
that the media are going to downplay as
opposed to the things that they play up
so here's a perfect example last night
President Trump you spoke in Michigan in
the middle of his speech
he started talking about the Ford family
and he started talking about the fact
that the the board of Ford still has
people who are from the Ford family
sitting on it and he praises the quote
unquote Ford bloodlines
what he's pointing out is that the Ford
company was founded by Henry Ford
who is one of the most iconic American
industrial figures in human history one
most iconic industrial figures in
history literally the Ford production
process became the basis for a certain
philosophy of business it became the
basis both good and bad for a certain
philosophy of how human beings should
interact none of that is to say that
Henry Ford himself was a wonderful
wonderful dude in terms of his
anti-semitism he brutally was not I've
talked about the song and shat like four
days ago I referred to this on the show
before this controversy blew up right I
mean I talked about the fact that Henry
Ford was actually a vicious anti-semite
who published fully protocols of the
Elders of Zion based newspapers from
like 1920 in 1927 was sued for libel and
had to shut down the newspaper then
received an award from the Nazi
government in 1938 so Henry Ford was was
a vicious horrible anti-semite he hated
Jews he thought the Jews formed a world
conspiracy against him and all the rest
do you think that's what Trump is
referring to when he talks about the
Ford bloodline here so Trump says this
about the Ford family and everybody
immediately jumps who he's he's
endorsing Ford's anti-semitism and
genetic and genetic eugenic views come
on come on this is so silly
here is Trump yesterday the company
founded by a man named Henry Ford good
bloodlines good bloodlines if you
believe in that stuff get good blood
they teamed up with the company founded
by Thomas Edison that's General Electric
that's good stuff that's good stuff and
you put it all together then they're all
looking down right now and they'd be
very proud of what they see this is why
I mean okay so is that a smart thing to
say well if you had historical awareness
wouldn't be a particularly smart things
to say but when he's talking about like
the bloodlines of the company or the
bloodlines of your family if it turns
out that your grandfather was president
you say the Roosevelt family that that's
that's a hell of a bloodline right there
if you said the Kennedy family that's a
hell of a bloodline then somebody goes
oh you mean Joseph Kennedy that vicious
anti-semite he was a vicious anti-semite
Joseph Kennedy right that people be like
that's not what he's talking about do
you really think that he's referring to
Henry Ford's anti-semitism there he's
dog whistling to the alt-right when he
refers to the four bloodlines of course
not this blew up on social media last
night obviously because Trump's a racist
and we have to impute racism rather than
ignorance to him again there's a very
simple solution to Trump saying dumb
things and that is
the man's has dumb things he doesn't
know anything about history
okay Trump has it I I have friends who
have been to events where Trump has
literally said I've written more books
than I have read yeah Donald Trump is
not a master of American history he is
not fluent in American history
he doesn't know things okay so the
imputation of anti-semitism did
anti-semitism to him first of all based
on he's the most pro-israel president in
American history he's the most Pro
Jewish president probably in American
history given the fact that he has
promulgated executive orders that have
tried to protect Jews on campus
he's been outspoken against
anti-semitism repeatedly for all of the
talk about his associations would be
alright in 2016 I was one people talked
extensively about it he forcibly
disassociated from himself from them in
in mid 2017 and beyond none of that was
good but to pretend that Donald Trump is
like a vicious anti-semite when his
grandkids are Jewish is insane it's not
correct and she's not correct okay so
Trump that was that that was dumb
controversy number one then there was
some controversy number two which is
President Trump saying silly things
so yesterday President Trump mentioned
that he has tested daily for a corona
virus and he does like a full on South
Park routine here about being positive
on a test versus negative on a test that
has been like a long time comedy but for
a very long time it's pretty it's a
pretty old chestnut here's President
Trump doing it unintentionally I had a
two-week regimen of hydroxychloroquine
and I've taken it I think just about two
weeks I think it's another day so and
I'm still here I'm still here and I
tested very positively in a in another
sense so this morning yeah I tested
positively towards negative right so now
I tested perfectly this morning meaning
meaning I tested negative he can realize
in the middle of that that's good that
this became a trend too because oh my
gosh from some positively negatively
negatively positively hey then there was
the stupid controversy over whether he
wore a mask in Michigan so there are all
sorts of news reports he didn't wanna
mask when he was in Michigan first of
all he's not positive for Kovan 19 he
would be in isolation if you're positive
for Kovan 19 the man's tested literally
every day every single day he's the most
protected person in America from kovin
19 and as it turns out he actual
I was wearing a mask right there was
there was a picture that emerged that
behind closed doors he was wearing a
mask
in other words when he was in close
proximity to other people he was wearing
a mask and then when he spoke he was not
wearing a mask which by the way is also
what reporters have been doing in the
White House rose garden
so yesterday from explain I don't want
to give the media the pleasure of seeing
me with a mask on now listen I think
this is dumb I do I think it's really
stupid I think that the president when
he is out in public should be wearing a
mask not because I think that he is
making other people unsafe but because
he sets a good example to a lot of front
followers that if you are in public with
other people you should be wearing a
mask I think that's a good thing I do I
mean Mike Pence has been wearing a mask
so I think that that's a good thing here
was president from yesterday though
saying I'm never gonna give the
satisfaction to the media and listen
this is how Trump rolls but is this a
major like did Trump cough on people and
give them Corona yesterday he did not
and if you were wearing a mask would he
be protecting himself from Corona no he
would not so on a practical level from
container no.1 by wearing by not wearing
a mask
it just says if you don't have company
team you're not endangering anybody by
not wearing a mask
that said it's asymptomatic you know
what you may not know so you should wear
a mask listen I think the Trump should
do it I do I think you should put on a
mask when he is when he is in public but
do I think that it's like a major
controversy of the day of course not
said it turned into the major
controversy of the day of course it did
because we live in the stupidest
possible timeline there was president
Trump yesterday but I didn't want to
give the pleasure of seeing
okay so again is this like a major
conference you know did that bring the
Michigan Attorney General to national TV
say maybe we will prosecute Ford for not
making Trump wear eye mask
Trump is no longer welcome in our state
I wonder maybe she's a Democrat it
occurs to me that maybe the Michigan
AG's a Democrat for saying something as
dumb as this on national TV is the
president no longer welcome in Michigan
well I will say speaking on behalf of my
department and my office that's right
the president is like a petulant child
who refuses to follow the rules and I
have to say this is no joke I think that
we're gonna have to have a very serious
consequence a tional afford in the event
that they permitted the president to be
and publicly in closed places in
violation of the order they knew exactly
what the order was I mean come on come
on they're gonna go up to Ford Trump is
banned from the state what he can do
arrest him when it comes to Eric Z
didn't wear a mask on what legal grounds
would you do this and what are the
damages that you can prove is very very
silly stuff okay so then we'll get to
controversies that are not selling yeah
because it turns out that there are some
conference in America that are not
selling and Joe Biden is making himself
the issue and say it's amazing all Joe
Biden literally for Joe Biden to win
basically all he has to do is this is
like the perfect situation for Biden all
he has to do is lie in his casket all
day in his basement and he will be the
president that's all he has to do just
almost literally be dead I just just eat
and drink and say nothing for six months
and he will likely be President
according to the polling numbers and he
can't do it because Joe Biden it turns
out is a terrible terrible candidate and
he says terrible things and his ideology
about race is awful as well I'll get to
that momentarily first let's talk about
the fact that we are home more than
usual these days that doesn't mean you
don't have to keep track your property
means you have to keep track of your
property even more than usual these days
you want to know who's walking up on
your front step I've had a couple
friends robbed in the last couple of
weeks alone and thanks to ring they at
least had that on tape and we're able to
hand
tape over to the police and they were
alert to people who are at their front
door which is really important since
actually one of them was home at the
time ring gives you the protection that
you need I've been using ring devices
for years in my property ring video
doorbell let you answer the door and
check in on your home anytime keep an
eye on your doorstep speak to delivery
people when you can't come to the door
with the outdoor security cameras you
can check in on every part of your house
and never miss a moment smart lighting
brightens up blind spots it makes you
always come home to a break brightly lit
house which is really important also
they've got the full home security
system so you can protect your family
and your pets and your property and one
of the big things for me is knowing
where my kids are in my property at all
times even if I don't have an eye on
them get a special offer on the ring
welcome cap when you go to ring calm
slash been that welcome kit does include
the ring video doorbell three and the
chime Pro that's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today just go to ring.com slash Bend
again that is ring comm slash Ben it's
gonna make you and your family safer
ring comm slash Ben we're gonna get into
slow Joe and his vicious racism I mean
really this is this is actually it's
actual racism the media will brush it
off because he's a Democrat but it's
pretty damned races we'll get to that in
one second first let us talk about
several things first of all you should
subscribe to daily wire why well many
reasons first we actually have a Sunday
special this week that I think is a
blast all about science fiction litter
I'm a big sci-fi fan Orson Scott Card
the author of Ender's Game is on the
Sunday special this week you're really
gonna enjoy it it to kick it's something
completely different we talk about
writing style and strategy how you
outline for a story really fun stuff
from one of the all-time great science
fiction writers here's a little bit of a
taste my lawyer calls me he says well
Scott here's the good news they're gonna
take your script to pilot so it has a
chance to go on air but you're fired
they don't want you to show up on set
and I just laughed
okay so it is it is a blast you're going
to enjoy it also we have a backstage
next Wednesday May 27th at 4 p.m.
Pacific 7 p.m. Eastern Time so you'll
get to watch all of us from our various
hidey-holes in Southern California talk
to one another we'll see if Clavin is
still alive we'll check in on him and
see if he has actually turned into a
skeleton he's no longer Skeletor he's
actually turned into a skeleton we'll
check in on Clavin unfortunately Noel's
will probably be there as well so
that'll be unfortunate but if you enjoy
that sort of thing then head on over to
Daley wire also it is that time of the
week when we have when we reward one of
our daily wire subscribers today it is
cataract cowboy on twitter who
understands the importance of picking
the right mate in this picture a woman
in a patriotic gymnastics outfit
gracefully hangs upside down from a rope
with the world's most elite beverage
vessel resting closeby is very graceful
stuff my 8 months pregnant wife and her
left is tears tumbler nutrient tents
left his tears simultaneously provide
the energy to do socially distance
aerial sports nourish the growing body
of her unborn child and boost immune
response to protect from kovat that is
pretty spectacular stuff right there I
mean that's that's wild so I'm gonna sue
she's professional at this because she's
eight months pregnant and she is hanging
from ribbons but that's pretty
spectacular stuff right there thanks for
the pic Congrats on the growing family
that is awesome stuff if you would like
to be featured in our daily wire tumbler
section every Friday all you have to do
is be a subscriber have the daily wired
tumbler take a creative picture and then
make sure that you has tagged us and and
add us and you may end up featured on
the bench Schapiro show it next week so
go check that out you're listening to
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so this is pretty astonishing stuff
so Joe Biden is running against Donald
Trump or or shall we say sleeping
against Donald Trump and he is all he
has to do is just avoid controversy
that's all he has to do well today
he's on a show called Breakfast Club
which is popular podcast and he decided
at the end of the interview that he was
going to tell a black man that black
people have to that this this host who
is black is saying you know when you
have a chance to come up to New York
many of us wear black have questions for
you about your policies which by the way
you don't have to not vote for Joba you
could still vote for Joe Biden have
questions about his policies right this
is called American politics
you can even demand things from
candidates in exchange for your vote in
terms of policy now in terms of bribery
but in terms of policy now you can do
those things
hey but Joe Biden literally says out
loud the quiet part which is the
Democrats believe that you're not
actually black if you won't vote for Joe
Biden so Joe Biden actually says this
which is a hell of a thing to say
coming from Joe Biden I mean that it is
pure like imagine any Republicans saying
this about about black folks in America
and and the blowback it doesn't matter
at any level every Republican in America
would be asked about it every single one
let alone the presidential candidate
it's incredible
so here's Joe Biden being blatantly
racist I mean this is blatantly racist
listen you gotta come see us when you
come to New York VP Biden as well it's a
long way until November we got more
questions you got more questions right
Ellen if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for mere Trump and you
ain't black
that is insane that's an insane thing to
say even some folks on the Left are
upset by this not all of them got people
like Dave waggle the reporter over at
the Washington Post trying to make
excuses for for Joe Biden but he liked
Dave waggle actually tweeted this out so
he's covering politics for the
Washington Post used to be over at Slate
he says the you ain't black thing is a
combustion of two pretty well known
factors CTG rattles people with direct
questions that's the the host
Charlamagne the shaman that got that's
who that is and and Joe Biden gets set
off if he thinks someone is questioning
his record oh so that's what happened he
didn't just say the black people aren't
black if they don't vote for him oh it
really he was just a little rattled
michael says I've seen it when Biden got
challenged
by climate activists or someone had a
question about guns q for a second 60
second stem-winder about how the
questioner should check the facts and
I'm the only one who's beating the NRA
etc you might ask why doesn't he pivot
to a better topic
he doesn't pivot if you doubt he's got
the best positions and experience he'll
tell you you're wrong you should vote
for someone else so far this has gotten
him the nomination and a poll lead um
well question it's one thing to say I
have the best record on guns so if you
don't like it don't vote for me to say
if you don't vote for me you are not
black is an insane thing to say a Joe
Biden is not the decider as to who is
black and who is not in fact it turns
out you know who's the decider on who is
black and who is not it turns out that
your race is the decider on who is black
and who is not it is objectively
determinable who is black and who is not
right this is like we know this because
Rachel Dolezal tried to claim she was
black and she was not black right so Joe
Biden does not get to be the decider on
whether you are black and certainly you
don't get to decide whether somebody is
black based on ideology it turns out
that race and ideology are completely
non congruent right there are plenty of
white liberals and plenty of white
conservatives you don't decide
somebody's politics based on their race
and if you do you are doing racism this
would be open acknowledgement of racism
but he puts that out there and watch
it'll blow over within 5 minutes now
what it may have done happiest person in
America take Hummel Harris because
Kamala Harris chided Joe Biden is a
racist during the primaries and now
she's being actively considered as his
VP so Amy Klobuchar hardest hit last
yesterday was announced that Joe Biden
might pick Amy Klobuchar and the whoa
crowd on Twitter was like you can't pick
a white woman it has to be a black woman
well now Joe Biden basically just set
himself on fire here so he's gonna have
to pick a black woman right just just to
prove that he is not a racist he's gonna
have to pick a black woman and then the
black person can come out and say cannon
can make the judgment as to who was
legitimately black and who's
legitimately not or something right that
will be the tactic that Joe takes so
Kamala Harris is the happiest candidate
in America today right she is so happy
Stacey Abrams is now like Stacey Abrams
is festooning her house with VP colors
it's it like she's getting and she's
getting all of her all of her bunting
out it's very
Joba it's an unbelievable thing that
like why would that even occur to him
you're not legitimately black now the
answer to that not occurring to him is
because there's a narrative that has
taken place in democratic circles that
you are only in that black
should only vote for Democrats because
only Democrats care about black people
and they are attempting to push this
narrative Democrats are and members of
the media by suggesting that Trump's
handling of coronavirus is racial that
Republicans belief in reopening is
racial we saw this by Hurricane Katrina
by the way I predicted this I think
three months ago right I think fully
three months ago I predicted that the
Democrats were going to turn the corner
virus pandemic into a racial issue that
it was not going to remain a national
crisis they were immediately going to
attempt to try and racialize this thing
such that they could claim that the
Trump administration was botching this
because they don't care enough about
black and brown people and that's
exactly what Democrats aren't something
to do right now and that's why you're
hearing Biden say stuff like that right
the tacit assumption that Biden is
making is that Donald Trump hates and
doesn't care about black people and thus
if you are black you should vote for Joe
Biden right you don't actually care
about or believe in black people if you
don't agree with Joe Biden on the issues
because Joe Biden is Pro black and the
the tacit assumption there is that
Donald Trump is a vicious racist right
that is the the tacit assumption making
that tacit assumption explicit is a
piece today in the Washington Post by
Michele Morris it's called the
us-and-them pandemic shows America is
still impervious to black pain so I
gotta be honest with you I have not
thought once about the about the notion
that we should skimp on medical
resources based on race in a pandemic
that's an insane contention but she
suggests that basically if you're pro
lock down is because you don't care
about black and hispanic people enough
how does she come to this bizarre
conclusion she quotes a political
scientist named Evan Lieberman he's an
MIT professor who has studied the public
response to AIDS and HIV based on ethnic
and racial factors he suspected that
collecting disaggregated racial data
ANCOVA 19 could have unintended
consequences yes it would help identify
areas of vulnerability or need but when
that vulnerability was then attached to
a specific racial or ethnic category he
feared it could harm the very group the
data collection was supposed to help he
wrote it's not difficult to imagine that
if Cova 19 comes to be understood as a
black epidemic this will create false
impressions for many white Americans in
the United States is racially polarized
an effectively segregated society which
we are not that the virus is quote not
our problem leading to decreased demand
for and compliance with public health
directives Michele Norris says not our
problem is an undercurrent in the
largely white reopening America protests
popping up daily around the countries
we're gonna rationalize this thing if
you want to reopen it's because you're
racist you don't care about black and
brown people she's not our problem is
the undercurrent when people refuse to
wear masks in public and not our problem
is the conclusion one cannot help but
draw when one studies the calendar and
sees that the protest commenced around
the same time that the data on racial
disparities became a central storyline
in coven 19 news coverage well I can
help draw that conclusion because that
conclusion does not follow okay first of
all the subsets on racial disparities
were coming out fairly early in in all
of this when lockdown was still
incredibly popular the end of the
lockdown talk started once the curve was
flattened that's what actually drove all
this was people saying okay we're not
gonna die if we go back to work so can
we go back to work now I love this this
is what Michele Norris says some of the
modes out argue that they're not our
problem is a coincidence of timing
perhaps it is fueled by disassociation
if the viral load is concentrated in
nursing homes meatpacking plants prisons
and black communities than those who
don't have connections to any of those
places are going to feel less threatened
and boldly venture out into the world as
stay at home orders are relaxed well
that would make more sense right I mean
it would make sense I don't make a
decision on lockdown based on the race
of the people acquiring this I do make a
decision based on where I'm going to go
today based on the heaviness of the
viral load right I would not travel
today into New York City I would travel
today into Florida or Texas does that
have to do with the racial constituency
of New York or does it have to do with
the risk factors in New York but she
says she says I doubt it
Post reporter Stephanie McCrimmon
recently visited a wealthy area of shops
and restaurants in Alpharetta Georgia or
crowds of unworried in unmask people
were eating drinking touching and
throwing caution to the wind she spoke
with two men on the sprawling plaza
sipping beer on a sunny day when you
start seeing where the cases are coming
from the demographics I'm not worried
one of the men said his friend chimed in
I know what people are gonna say those
selfish idiots are killing our old
people and then the friend noted he
wasn't worried because of well you know
the demographics served up the final
punctuation how do you give up a day
like this really how the two men were
enjoying that beautiful spring day in
Georgia a state where black people make
up 83% of the coronavirus hospital
patients even though they constitute one
third of the population well hold up so
now because he said that the
demographics don't threaten him meaning
that he is young that's what people are
generally talking about when they talk
about the demographics and we have when
we talk about what is threatening people
they're talking pre-existing conditions
age those are the two main factors right
those are the factors everybody is
analyzing because by the way those are
the factors that matter if you are black
and you are young and you don't have
pre-existing conditions there's no
evidence you're gonna die at a higher
rate than if you are white and young you
have no pre-existing conditions this is
not a racialized issue it's just that
there are other cross-cutting currents
that make this disproportionately fall
in one community or another so to try
and turn this into a racial narrative is
of course a political move and the
political move is that the suggestion is
that the the American population is
calling for lockdown because secretly
they are racist Michele Norris says we
can use words such as demographics and
comorbidities to dance around the
subject of race but we cannot skirt the
flag the fact that what is the nuisance
for one person is another person's
plague
not my problem is not the right response
so somehow this got racialized but
everything gets racialized this is the
narrative so the narrative in democratic
circles is that everything at root is
racial and because everything at rue is
racial you aren't really black if you
vote for Republicans because of course
everything Republicans do is motivated
by brutal racism now what this doesn't
necessitate for Democrats is neglecting
cases that do not fit into this eat this
neat and easy narrative of Republicans
are the vicious racists in society and
the great victim is the great
victimization is happening by white
Americans against black Americans
disproportionately and so that dictates
which events are going to be covered and
how those events are going to be covered
so the media for example will put heavy
focus on the AR berry shooting in
Georgia that's totally fine by the way
that was a complete botch like that
should be the focus of media coverage
was an awful shoot by the evidence there
now three people have been arrested
correctly by the police for murder
including this is now including the
person who is taping this thing from
behind that is a very very good thing
that's the process working we have not
yet seen evidence that the people who
were involved in the shooting we're
doing so because our Barry was black
we're gonna find that out we do have
evidence of corruption inside the DA's
office because they left two scopes they
were friendly with some of those people
okay that receives inordinate coverage
good but there was a case yesterday that
receives no coverage okay look virtually
no national coverage this was a case
which you would assume is kind of
relevant given all the issues we've been
having in nursing homes there's a tape
those going around the Detroit Police
Department said in a statement they
arrested a 20 year old male in
connection
the assault and battery of an elderly
male inside the Westwood Nursing Center
on the northwest side of the city
according to the Detroit News and tape
emerged it's a 20 year old black man and
he's beating the living hell out of an
elderly nursing home patients he appears
to be wiping the blood from an elderly
male in an attempt to hide the wounds
both were apparently patients at the
nursing home according to the Detroit
News it's not clear why the 20 year old
suspect was being treated there the
nursing home was unaware of the assault
until they saw the video said Detroit
Police Chief James Craig we're still
investigating that aspect of the case we
do have a suspect in custody
additional unconfirmed videos of the
suspect assaulting other elderly
individuals have surfaced across social
media
it appears the assault was racially
motivated okay so that that is the the
police talking that the assault was
racially motivated now does this mean
that black people are willy-nilly going
around beating up old people of course
not of course not
you cannot form a referendum on the
basis of anecdotal evidence but the
media are very fond of drawing referenda
on the basis of anecdotal evidence even
if the evidence doesn't completely
support it why because again it backs a
narrative so here's the reality we
should cover all crimes we should make
sure that all crimes get covered and we
should base our trendlines on actual
data not on anecdotal evidence but
because the media have a narrative in
mind that is why in the end Joe Biden
will be fine for saying that black
people are not black I'm mostly vote for
Joe Biden because that falls right in
line with the easy media narrative which
is that everything is about racist
Republicans demeaning black people and
everything Democrats do is in defense of
black people against those racist
Republicans that dictates the media
coverage Cates which stories get covered
it dictates how presidential candidates
are covered because again you don't
cover Democrats like Republicans because
Republicans are evil and Democrats are
good that's the bottom line here and you
won't cover the story in Detroit the
same way that you will cover other
stories if the right if the races were
reversed by the way if that were a white
man in a nursing home beating up elderly
black people you'd be the front page of
every newspaper in America because one
supports the generalized narrative that
America is a vicious racist country and
the other does not support that
narrative the other supports a different
narrative which is that there are in
fact racists in many different
communities including in the black
community right that that is not a
narrative that anybody wants to draw
particularly not in the press so this
will go completely uncovered it will
disappear from the news and of course
I'm not equated bury shooting somebody
died in that case today I'm just talking
about
media coverage of the of the two stories
which has been completely disparate okay
time for some things that I hate well
it's good to know that many Democrats
are now rallying around Joe Biden no
matter what he does a columnist before
the nation names katha pollitt claimed
on Wednesday she would vote for Joe
Biden quote if he boiled babies and ate
them makes sense
Pilate shrugged off Senate staffer Tara
Reid sexual assault allegation against
Biden declaring quote I would vote for
Joe Biden if you boil babies and hate
them
he wasn't my kanzen it but taking back
the White House is that important she
says I cannot believe that a rational
person can grasp the disaster that is
Donald Trump and withhold their support
from Biden because of Tara Reid I would
say this even if I had no problems with
Reid's account I take women's
accusations very seriously but there
have always been reasons to be skeptical
about this one to believe Reid you have
to believe that Biden put her up against
the wall and penetrated her with her
fingers on the spur of the moment in a
hallway in a Capitol Complex where she
says she was looking for him to give him
his gym bag this corridor is a public
space to believe raid you have to
believe Biden would take that risk
whether or not you believe Reid you
should vote for Joe Biden if he's the
nominee we don't have the luxury of
sitting out the election to feel morally
pure or send a message about sexual
assault and believe women that will not
help women at all or anyone else so that
is some that is pretty deranged insane
stuff obviously and I'm glad to see that
some Democrats are just embracing their
inner aide that's exciting stuff
meanwhile James Carville who stumped
very hard for Joe Biden against Bernie
Sanders he was out there saying the
Trump is going to get his quote fat ass
beat which is typical James Carville
it'd be alright they'd go get his fat
beat we can get to our 90 to 95
electoral votes and we'll change nothing
if we go and take it to them and talk
about what a massive fat failure he is
then we can run away with this thing and
you can defeat it's not ideas not just
to defeat Trump you have to defeat Trump
ISM okay so there's James Carville going
off and again the fact that so many
people are willing to back Joe Biden no
matter what this does put it shine a
spotlight on the criticism people who in
2016 said I'll vote for Trump just to
defeat Hillary so now
Joe Biden just said if he trunk the same
guy who was telling people won't put
y'all back in Chains to black people
that Mitt Romney's gonna put them all
back in changes now saying you're not a
legit black person unless you vote for
Joe Biden by the way Joe Biden gaps more
than any candidate I have ever seen
remember when they were the media were
shouting at Mitt Romney what about your
- remember that Joe Biden counts more
than any candidate in history yesterday
Joe Biden suggested the tenets senator
Tammy Baldwin of Wisconsin has quote a
great deal of lift in heft um I don't
think that that's what that means what
you think it means Joe let me ask you
about Wisconsin's other senator and
Democrat Tammy Baldwin is she is she on
your list is she being vetted as a
potential vice presidential pick what I
don't want to do and I'm not going to do
is list the people who are being
considered but Tammy is an incredibly
competent United States Senator with a
great deal of heft and lift to her what
she's able to do and she's capable of
doing almost anything I can pick her up
with one hand I've been exercising if
you'd like to have a if you'd like to
have a push-up contest right now I will
have a pushup and then I will bench
press Stacey Abrams I've been working
out so I've moved up from bench pressing
calm low to bench pressing Staci and
Tammy Baldwin I can tell you that you
can really a man can really get a chest
workout by bench pressing senator
Baldwin wait how is this the person that
you guys do I get that you decide on
this instead of the old socialist I was
quite happy about it but I'm just gonna
point out that there's still plenty of
time before this election this is like
really there's a lot of talk about the
the various polling data showing that
Joe Biden is up in a lot of these states
well he's gonna have to rely on a couple
of things one converting undecided to
vote for Joe Biden and two he's gonna
have to convert he's going to have to
get a lot of black people who stayed
home for Hillary Clinton to come out for
Joe Biden on the second one there are
some doubts there are some doubts this
is not captain popularity among black
Americans the only reason he's popular
among black Americans is because of the
halo of Obama that still glows around
him if it were not for Barack Obama
black Americans would not be
particularly friendly to Joe Biden the
man was a sponsor of the 1994 crime bill
talked extensively about it
he was as as kumla harris says against
forced busing which again was both these
things I bet by the way our policies
which I agree forced busing is bad
policy and
so and the crime bill was good policy
but that's not exactly going to kind of
layer over you racialized narrative the
Democrats want to tell again I have to
play this clip again because Joe Biden
literally saying to black people they're
not black unless they vote for him is an
incredible pitch figuring out whether
you're for mayor Trump and you ain't
black yeah that unbelievable
unbelievable really incredible stuff
okay meanwhile China is heightening its
grip on Hong Kong so while we all fight
about stupidity over here well we all
fight about whether Trump is wearing a
mask
at a at a Michigan and a Michigan car
plant or whatever there are actual
things happening in the world that are
incredibly dangerous China which again
we're someone else let's say Wu hen by
Reza's parents Kamala Harris put forward
resolution this week that said if you
say woo Han virus or Chinese virus it's
because you're racist against Chinese
Americans which is insane because last I
checked Lu Han is not in America Chinese
Americans are American and one thing has
nothing to do with the other but the
same people who are out there saying
Trump is being too mean to China China
meanwhile is now trying to basically
overrun Hong Kong I mean that they're
just taking advantage of the pandemics
you destroy all opposition and what was
supposed to be a free state when when
Hong Kong which is a peninsula on the
coast of what used to be China when Hong
Kong was abandoned by the British and
what was one of the worst deals in human
history the guarantee was supposed to be
that Hong Kong had its own independent
governments even if it interacted with
the Chinese government on a fairly solid
level it was it was the idea that they
were the same country but they were
basically two different territories
governed differently Hong Kong was
supposed to be able to retain
fundamental freedoms trying to just
decided they were going to carve away at
that the latest from the New York Times
China's top leaders on Friday made a
show of strength in to confront defiance
in Hong Kong and the economic damage
wrought by the corona virus outbreak
even as they acknowledge that both had
dealt a blow to the ruling Communist
Party's agenda on Hong Kong the
leadership struck a hard-line at the
annual meeting of China's legislature
unveiling a plan to impose sweeping new
security laws that would place the
territory more firmly under Beijing's
thumb and cracked down on
anti-government protests but the move is
likely to incite more unrest and outrage
in the semi-autonomous territory as well
as criticism from abroad well not if
Democrats have anything to do with it or
the NBA right if the NBA criticizes it
then China
cuts them off at the knees on the
economy the premier addressing the
opening of the National People's
Congress declared the government had
achieved a decisive victory against the
corona virus outbreak and that the
country had shown great resilience but
in a break with tradition
China abandoned setting an annual growth
target for 2020 recognizing the
difficulties in restarting its economy
amid a pandemic premiere at Lee Kikwang
who is the second-ranked in the
communist party hierarchy behind G made
his speech to nearly three thousand
Congress delegates wore masks as they
set neat rows in the ornate Great Hall
of the People he pledged to I'll blunt
the impact of the slowdown with lint
with goals to limit inflation on
unemployment he said China will face
challenges like never before however we
have unique political and institutional
strengths a strong economic foundation
enormous market potential and hundreds
of millions of intelligent and
hardworking people the horizons for ties
in China's developments are full of
promise the Congress outlined the
party's plans disclosed in a surprise
move Thursday night for new laws in Hong
Kong to prevent and punish secession
subversion and foreign infiltration that
has blamed for fueling unrest in the
city the legislation would also allow
the mainland's feared security agencies
to set up their operations publicly in
Hong Kong for the first time so now the
Chinese Politburo will be running Hong
Kong security which means basically they
are now going to imprison or kill
anybody who opposes Chinese rule in Hong
Kong so while the rest of the world is
deeply disturbed by the power grab
happening in Viktor orbán's hungry it
seems that people are willing to ignore
what is going on in China and to pretend
that China's control of w-h-o is no big
deal Rachel Maddow has some very strong
words about president Trump saying that
he is going to defund the w-h-o unless
they stop being a Chinese catspaw when's
the last time Rachel Maddow spoke out
I don't watch her shows maybe it was
yesterday but I doubt it when was the
last time she spoke out about Chinese
authoritarianism overtaking the free
state of Hong Kong in a speech detailing
the plan Wang chenna Politburo member
and first vice chairman of the Congress
pointed to the protesters in Hong Kong
who to face the national flag and
surrounded Beijing's offices in the city
as posing a threat to China's
sovereignty he also said in long-held
suspicions by Beijing that foreign
governments had incited the recent
protest in Hong Kong
even though evidence to support this is
limited Wang declared law based and
forceful measures must be taken to
prevent stop and punish such activities
this of course drew immediate alarm in
Hong Kong the Hong Kong stock market
slumps more than 5% on Friday the
unusual arrangements for Congress
meeting this year reflect continued
worries that China has
actually totally contain the outbreak
and that they continue to lie to the
world one of the reasons that Hong Kong
wasn't that hard hit is because the
government of Hong Kong simply did not
believe the Chinese government when they
said there was no human to human
transmission but using the cover of
coronavirus in order to destroy the
freedom of Hong Kong is an amazingly
powerful move and you're seeing the
Chinese do this with with the WH o'the
regard to Taiwan trying to cut off
Taiwan at the knees China is an evil
empire China is a vicious vicious evil
government and to pretend that they are
just a responsible actor on the world
stage is utterly insane they are a
geopolitical threat to the United States
their geopolitical threat to their
neighbors and they are using this
opportunity in order to strengthen their
grip on a variety of countries in their
immediate sphere the the if you think
the Joe Biden is gonna be harsh on the
Chinese you got another thing coming
I have yet to see any evidence that Joe
Biden is gonna be harsh on China at all
and in fact it seems like he is spending
more time ripping on president from for
being harsh on China than being harsh on
China himself this should retain this
should remain a focus of American
activity and if it is not we are we are
definitely missing the the boat when it
comes to a geopolitical crisis that is
going to be fomented over the course of
the coming decade alrighty we'll be back
here a little bit later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here next week I hope you
have a wonderful Memorial Day weekend a
meaningful Memorial Day weekend as we
remember Americans we've lost in battle
as you remember that the people who have
fought for our freedoms so let's keep
that in mind obviously as we celebrate a
long weekend and we will see you here
next week I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
swenerton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20